it's not doing well may I say she is not
she is not doing well Oprah Winfrey
fought back tears on the Today Show
talking about the backlash surrounding
her best friend Gayle King obviously all
things pass she will be okay but she
hasn't slept in two days let me get you
up to speed on Tuesday's CBS this
morning aired Gail's interview with
former WNBA star Lisa Leslie in the
wide-ranging interview Gayle asked Kobe
Bryant's longtime friend about his
tragic death in January he will be
missed but he would not be forgotten
that's for sure
Gayle also asked about his 2003 rape
charge and subsequent criminal case it's
been said that his legacy is complicated
because of sexual assault charge which
was dismissed in 2003 2004 is it
complicated for you as a woman as a WNBA
player Kobe was never like that I just
never see have ever seen him being the
kind of person that would be do
something to violate a woman or be
aggressive in that way is not the person
that I know the network later posted a
clip of that specific moment and people
got mad even Snoop Dogg took to social
media with an explicit message for Gayle
we expect more from you Gayle don't you
hang out with Oprah why are you
attacking us we owe people on Thursday
Gayle responded to the backlash on
Instagram I had only seen the clip that
you saw I'd be extremely angry with me
too I am mortified I'm embarrassed and I
am very angry and she shared her side of
the story
unbeknownst to me my network put up a
clip from a very wide-ranging interview
totally taken out of context and when
you see it that way it's very jarring
jarring to me so I've been told
or have been advised to say nothing but
that's not good enough for me I reached
out to Lisa because I know that she's a
longtime friend of Kobe's to talk about
his legacy and their friendship
we had a really wide-ranging interview
talked about many things and yes we
talked about that court case because
that court case has also come up and I
wanted to get Lisa's take on it as a
friend who knew him well what she
thought where that should stand when
Kobe was 24 he was charged with one
count of felony assault after a then 19
year old woman went to the police
claiming he'd sexually assaulted her in
his Colorado hotel room back in 2003 the
case was dropped in 2004 after the
accuser declined to testify the same
woman also filed a civil lawsuit which
was settled out of court
in 2005 in a statement to ET a
spokesperson for CBS News explained
quote Gail conducted a thoughtful
wide-ranging interview with Lisa Leslie
about the legacy of Kobe Bryant an
excerpt was posted that did not reflect
the nature and tone of the full
interview we are addressing the internal
process that led to this and changes
have already been made she's not she's
not doing well and feels that she was
put in a really terrible position
enter Oprah in the context of the
interview everyone seemed fine including
Lisa Leslie and it was only because
somebody at the network put up that clip
and that and and I can see how people
would obviously be very upset if you
thought that Gail was just trying to
press to get you know an answer for Lisa
Leslie but she obviously all things pass
she will be okay but she hasn't slept in
two days the media mogul opened up about
the whole ordeal and got emotional I
think the last 24 hours for your best
friend have been pretty difficult after
that interview with Lisa Leslie about
Kobe and I just wondered just how she's
doing and it's not doing well may I say
she is that she is not doing well
because she has now death threats and
has to now travel with security and
she's feeling very much attacked you
know Bill Cosby is texting from
is tweeting from jail tweeting from jail
yeah you heard that right Bill Cosby is
writing from jail thinking snoop for
calling out Gale I think anybody can
criticize anything but the misogynist
vitriol and the attacking to the point
where it is dangerous to be in the
streets alone because it's not just the
people who are attacking it's the other
people who take that message and feel
like they can do whatever they want to
because of it now Oprah says she's just
standing by her friend you know I was on
the phone with her this morning I was on
the phone with her last night I was on
the phone with her and I'd be before I
think you you stand in the gap you try
to be there for your friends but it's
this is very hard because when you have
social media and the force of social
media and particularly people who didn't
see either interview making attacks and
I think everybody has the right to have
their opinion but to do it with such
vitriol is hate and meanness get you a
bestie like Oprah of course you can
count on et to bring you all the latest
on this story and more so make sure to
keep it locked right here until next
time I'm Hallie Stevens see you soon